You just had the night of your life in beautiful
Las Vegas, Nevada. You spent hours shooting craps,
dancing in clubs, and eating more than your
fill at the famous All You Can Eat Buffets.
You’re staggering back to your hotel room, high on
life, in the early hours of the morning when you
notice something strange: A long, dark tunnel just
off the side of the strip. You didn’t notice it on
the way in, perhaps because you were distracted by
all the glitz, glamor, and hypnotic casino lights.
You see the tunnel, and your over
stimulated mind feels drawn to it...
You stumble in and start walking. During
your walk, you can feel your bones cracking.
They don’t shatter, like you’ve just
been hit by a train, they...shift.
You feel the entire shape of you
bending into something different.
But it doesn’t stop with your skeleton. Your
organs start to feel strange, and then your skin.
In the complete darkness of the tunnel, you have
no idea what’s going on, so you just keep walking.
Eventually, you find your way into a
lush, green forest. It’s beautiful,
but it feels like it should be a million
miles away from the arid desert of Nevada.
You were only in the tunnel
for a few minutes. What gives?
“Hello?” You call out. “Is anybody there?”
No answer.
You explore further into this empty forest. It’s
trees as far as the eye can see, but no animals.
That’s when you see something that catches your
eye: A puddle of crystal-clear water. But it’s not
the puddle itself that draws your attention, it’s
what reflects back at you when you stare into it.
At first, you can hardly believe it,
but as you move your mouth in shock
and the reflection moves its mouth
too, it’s suddenly all too real.
You’ve been turned into a fox.
An orange, bushy-tailed fox.
You scream, and bolt all the way back to the
tunnel that led you here. You sprint through,
as you feel your entire body changing once
more. When you finally hit the wall of dry
Vegas heat on the other side, you’re
human again. You breathe a sigh of relief,
and stumble back to your hotel room. The next
day, you only vaguely remember what happened,
and because you’re not crazy, you
assume it was all just a wild dream.
What you just encountered is a Euclid Class SCP
known as SCP-2746 - a seemingly innocent tunnel
near the Vegas strip which holds
a portal to a fantastical world,
designated by the Foundation as SCP-2746-1.
By the time the Foundation discovered
and secured the SCP-2746 tunnel,
and began sending their field agents and
researchers on fact-finding expeditions inside,
the place was already a ghost town.
A forested land mass approximately
111 kilometers in diameter, with no notable
signs of life. The Foundation discovered that
this place had a strange effect on people
and animals who came in from our world.
Humans who entered assumed the forms of a random
animal, but retained their intelligence and
vocal cords, creating talking animals. Animals
brought into 2746-1 retained their animalistic
intelligence, but grew human-like vocal
chords, allowing them to repeat simple phrases.
Before the mass exodus or extinction event that
left 2746-1 barren, the Foundation figured out
this place was populated by a whole civilization
of intelligent animals - like something out of a
fairytale. These animals, through a mix
of brains and magic, were able to leave
written records and create impressive
architecture, like homes and places of worship.
Foundation researchers became fascinated
with how exactly this society operated,
and what could have led to its sudden downfall.
Thanks to a mix of advanced archeology and
records left behind by the creatures,
this is what the Foundation determined:
The society these talking, intelligent animals
lived in was a kind of religious oligarchy -
meaning power was consolidated by the few in the
top social class. Society was divided into three
segments - Crafters, Scholars, and Honorables
- with the Crafters being the most powerful
members of society and Honorables being the least
powerful. The state-sponsored churches acted in
worship of a being simply called “The Maker”,
who fills a similar role to the Abrahamic God.
The Crafters, whose numbers totaled
13, were believed to be immortal,
and were responsible for building the majority
of the culture and architecture found in 2746-1.
The Scholars acted as their wise assistants, and
the Honorables were a mixed class of artists,
carpenters, and artisans. It seemed that
this culture had a pretty good thing
going. No system of currency was ever invented,
and the economy operated on a barter system.
The Foundation believes that,
initially, the citizens of this
world didn’t need to eat to survive, and so
only needed to barter for material goods.
Though it’s worth noting that these conditions of
immortality only apply to natives of the region.
People born on earth but assuming
animal forms while entering 2746-1
still need nutrition to survive.
However, a great tragedy soon caused a fundamental
shift in the balance of life and society within
2746-1. The Maker decided it wanted to test
or punish its subjects with two major changes:
First, humans would be forbidden
from entering the domain. And second,
The Maker now made the consumption of food
necessary for continued survival and sanity.
Nothing was ever the same.
Because nobody had needed to eat prior
to this, food stores had never been made,
and the inhabitants had no agricultural knowledge
that would allow them to easily mass-produce more.
As a result, while the Crafters and Scholars were
able to feed on fruits from luxurious private
gardens, the Honorables were forced to resort to
eating each other, or other inhabitants of 2746-1.
This began a bloody rift that split society
from the top down. One half, led by the powerful
Crafters Sari and Suwaird, wanted to preserve
society as it was and continue to worship The
Maker. Sari took the form of a Flemish giant
rabbit, and Suwaird appeared as a house cat.
The opposition, led by Former Crafters
Fredrick and Agathos - with the reluctant
help of a scholar named Clovis - wanted to
get revenge on The Maker for all he’d done,
and kill him, completely altering society.
Don’t be fooled by their appearances though.
Many of the inhabitants of 2746-1
wree fiercely intelligent sorcerers,
and the apocalyptic civil war they sparked came
to be known to the Foundation as Event Nachash.
Like many wars, there would be no real winners
here - only survivors. And
even then, not for long.
It was a bloody and horrific war. All
attempts at finding a diplomatic solution
failed. Fredrick and Agathos would not stop
until they had The Maker’s blood on their paws.
In the end, though, they were defeated,
and for their traitorous crimes they were
to be punished by Sari and Suwaird in
horrific ways to make examples of them.
Since neither could die, they were
given fates worse than death instead.
Fredrick was up first. Before the war, he’d been
a leader prized for his courage and ingenuity.
He’d created something known as the “great fire”,
which had provided the kingdom with light. For his
so-called “Atrocities against the maker”, he was
given the punishment of “permanent crucifixion”
and relocation to a place known as the “under
plane.” His snout was cut off his face,
and he was set permanently ablaze, in a manner
that would leave him forever suffering, and would
make him appear to look like a monster to all.
Next went Agathos. She was Fredrick’s sister,
and was seen as the mastermind of many
of their schemes. She would be forever
encased in white clay, and bled through
her eyes until the sin drains from her.
She’s now a living, crying statue, existing in a
state of permanent imprisonment for her part in
the crimes against The Maker. Clovis, because
her involvement in the coup was unwilling,
was given a more minor punishment - One of
her eyes was removed, and she was permanently
placed in a broken human body, effectively
banishing her from her home in 2746 - 1 forever.
Though they may have won, things didn’t end much
better for Sari and Suwaird. The civil war had
fractured their world, and in the aftermath, the
survivors chose to leave in hopes of finding a
better life elsewhere. Sari and Suwaird though,
felt partly responsible for everything that had
happened, and so they decided to remain in their
dying world. Before they themselves died - or
perhaps moved on to different forms, leaving their
animal bodies behind - they left a final note.
It was from this note that the Foundation
learned much of the story of SCP-2746.
This may seem like a pretty open and shut case.
Another magical realm destroyed by tragedy and
civil war, much like the land of Fantasy in
SCP-1762. But what’s really bizarre here is
that this is only the tip of the iceberg when it
comes to the stories of some of these key figures
in the Event Nachash. First, what became
of the two rebels, Agathos and Fredrick?
Today, they’re two parts of the feared and
deadly SCP-1913. Fredrick, now going by Freddie,
is a nightmarish, faceless fire-demon in
the form of a dog, slavishly devoted to
the protection of his sister - Agathos, now
known as Agatha. Still trapped in white clay,
her leaking blood now deadly to the touch.
Clovis is still believed to be in league
with Agathos and Fredrick, and may now be
related to the sinister SCP-1903 - a one-eyed,
rabbit-like human.But strangest of all is the
possible truth behind Sari and Suwaird, the
two devotees to The Maker who remained in 2746-1
until their very last breath. In all likelihood,
these two were once agents of the SCP
Foundation‘s infamous Las Vegas branch.
They took on these more animalistic
forms after their deaths.
Sari may have once been Agent Sarah Crowley,
a Japanese-American woman who died in the line
of duty in 1960. Suwaird was once Dr.
Stuart Hayward, Crowley’s partner - his
new name acting as a kind of fusion of
the first and last name he had in life.
This is only the beginning of the animal-themed
weirdness occurring around Site 45,
the Foundation’s Vegas branch, but this
series of anomalies - collected under
the term “Pitch Haven” - will
have to wait for another video.
After all, you know what they say:
What happens in Vegas, stays in Vegas.
Now check out “SCP-001 - The Scarlet
King” and “SCP-2317 - The Devourer
Of Worlds / A Door To Another World” for more
mind-blowing accounts from the SCP Foundation.